Gary by the way I think I should only
talk in New Jersey right [ __ ] I'm not
sure I want to talk anywhere else the
[ __ ] New Jersey I [ __ ] love you
guys
some real [ __ ] some real [ __ ]
[Music]
Jerzy this is SuperDuper fun for me
obviously like I am in a point in my
life where I get the great luxury of
going around the world and speaking and
visiting all sorts of great places but
to be back where I grew up feels [ __ ]
amazing I was I was doing some photos
and like even like the people I just
took photos with it was just like I'm
like this is [ __ ] Jersey you know
like it's a different flavor and I'm
really excited to be here so let's go
right into it I want to talk about um a
bunch of a bunch of different stuff
I hated some time for Q&A so line up for
that at some point but really what's
really interesting actually right before
two seconds before I took the stage a
gentleman grabbed me when I spoke in
Nashville we did like a consulting
session thing beforehand so I got like
two hours with different people and he
just grabbed me he's like hey I just
want you to know maybe I gotta take
stage right now but I took your advice
and I quit my job but I also moved back
to San Diego to do it and I decided to
pursue happiness over money and it
really hit me obviously you know when
you go on stage getting something that
feels that nice right before you go on
between being back home and hearing
something like that it's got me in a
really interesting mindset we also had a
really interesting drive for my office
here for the last hour with me and my
team just talking about a lot of
different stuff stuff that continues to
populate into my mind and most of all to
be very frank with everybody here when I
think about why would you be here today
Damon me different things that nature
like what what made you decide to spend
money and more importantly be frank
spend time to decide to come to this you
know I think the thing that has allowed
me to have a successful speaking career
is I'm desperate and I'm desperate as I
stand up here right now I'm desperate to
bring the most value while I'm on stage
I'm not interested in listen
I'm super [ __ ] capable to get mine
without getting anything from anybody in
this room I know what I'm doing on the
business front what I'm worried about is
why are you here and how through the
fact that you're actually here and not
watching this on video on YouTube from
it's just the right moment based on what
happened this week you know to me it's
the same game the biggest compliment
that I get on social media is when
somebody's trying to dog me by leaving a
comment of you'll [ __ ] this guy he says
the same [ __ ] and and I read that I'm
like that's exactly right [ __ ] I
have no [ __ ] interest in making up
[ __ ] for likes I'm gonna say the same
[ __ ] till the end I'm just waiting for
you to be ready to [ __ ] hear it
my friends it's uncomfortably simple out
there which means it's ridiculously
complicated what I mean by that is it's
no different what I'm going to talk to
you about whether its life or business
right now is really no different than if
this was a health conference I would
come and they would say how do we get
healthier and I would stand up here and
I would say I'd like you to eat better
and I'd like you to exercise every day
and I would say thank you very much and
I'm out that's actually the answer but
we don't want to hear it we'd rather buy
$29 [ __ ] apple vinegar [ __ ]
we'd rather buy some [ __ ] thing that
[ __ ] tightens your waist and
performance enhancement drugs and
[ __ ] ass implants and all this other
[ __ ] the reality is it's super simple if
for some way through a joke or an
analogy or a conversation here today or
an answer to a question I can get you to
start the process of genuinely being
able to handle judgement because you
finally are exhausted exhausted of
living your life based on other people's
opinions including stranger pants 96 and
your mom those two extremes though and
listen I know how many of you here
consume my content thank you so for the
ones that do you know my example is the
anonymous comment from sally pants 49 or
Rick's face or Jumpman 36 so it's the
two extremes it's you don't do things
because somebody says you're ugly or
you're stupid in a comment and you have
no idea who they are and they're hiding
between an avatar and some [ __ ] name
over here all the way to your mom that
that's what I spend all my time on from
this person to that person why is that
dictating you this one makes a lot of
sense to me
ironically that one makes a lot of sense
to me you all went through high school
you all lived life trying to do [ __ ] to
impress other people and we still do it
at scale the only thing listen I'm not
out here live in my life trying to
convince people how to make money like
me because making money is a talent like
singing and playing sports some people
are better at it than others can it be
taught of course it can be taught you
can always be better at something than
you were at a starting point I can be
better at dancing and singing and
basketball but I'm not [ __ ] gonna be
LeBron or Beyonce do I think people can
go from the kind of person that could
have a forty thousand dollar business to
a three million dollar business yes I do
do I think the person that has the
natural skill of a forty thousand dollar
a year business can make 45 million a
year no I do not do I think that we
completely need to recalibrate our
relationship with what success looks
like yes I do
like we're out here talking about making
a million dollars a year is the entry
point to balling when the 1% of
Americans top earners start at four
hundred forty thousand a year if you
make four hundred forty thousand dollars
a year in here you were in the 1%
earners in America one of the richest
countries in the world we're [ __ ]
confused my friends there's people here
that are 29 that are that think their
life's [ __ ] over next year cuz
they're gonna turn 30 and they don't
have their [ __ ] figured out there's
[ __ ] eighty eight year olds running
around Jersey that haven't [ __ ]
figured out their life I don't know what
miraculous situation of my parents
having sex at the right moment me being
born in the Soviet Union me growing up
in Edison and working in a liquor store
in Springfield but I'm telling you right
now whatever those dynamics were I sit
here back home with an amazing amount of
gratitude to my perspective forget about
anything else I've got going on I'm
trying to spend the rest of my life
to articulate my perspective so that you
can debate it against yours I'm not
trying to have you have my perspective
I'm just trying I don't think by the way
I don't think I'm right I don't think
I'm right I don't think I've earned the
ability to tell anybody anything I think
if I disappear tomorrow on some tragic
accident I trend on Twitter for a half a
day and then everybody moves on with
their lives like I get it but I'm
telling you if you're [ __ ] here today
please hear me
I can give you every tactic on LinkedIn
and tick-tock and Facebook and email and
text I can give it to you you keep
watching what I listen you want to have
business success watch what I do for the
rest of my life publicly copy it
verbatim but then put in your [ __ ] in it
and I promise you you'll be successful
coz I'm [ __ ] really good at my [ __ ]
that my friends is not the interesting
part the interesting part is why can I
do what I do why am I not scared to make
content on tick-tock when it's all
teenage people right
why am I willing to spend a ton of time
having a ton of different [ __ ] going on
and if something fails I don't give a
[ __ ]
I have vaynermedia I have a nurse sports
I have empathy I have a million things
going on
inevitably some of those things are
gonna fail things that shouldn't fail
but they're going to when you have 87
things you're not gonna go 87 and oh my
ability to deal with your judgment when
I go 70 and 13 is my strength why are
you only doing one thing
why don't you do [ __ ] cuz you're [ __ ]
scared the question is why like I'm just
trying to get to why like who like who's
gonna cast judgment my friends every
person here that's not a hundred percent
happy including myself is not doing
something because of judgment of
somebody else 100 that's the [ __ ]
game more importantly how do you start
shipping away in a world where you were
parented or your environment made you
that way how do you chip away here's how
you story tell that is the
responsibility and almost the way I feel
I live I have figured out over the last
decade or two really actually half
decade - a decade oh I have gift for gab
same reason I could sell same reason oh
I'm a good storyteller so I'm gonna give
you stories why do I put out those
analogies those clips say in the same
[ __ ] because there's only 15 truths I
just have to say them a million
different ways to catch you at the right
time with the right slang on the right
platform at the right moment I
appreciate you too I appreciate you too
that's what leads me to stories like you
know how in high school you were worried
about your zit and [ __ ] I used to be
scared of [ __ ] when I does it I was like
[ __ ] I don't go to [ __ ] school what I
learned through life was nobody gave a
[ __ ] about my zit they were worried
about their zit the number why do I tell
that story because right now people here
are in debt or can't do something
because they're just staying above
ground but that's because they bought a
house that was too expensive not using
rooms in that house and they don't have
the humility to sell that house and go
back to rent because they don't want
their friend from high school or their
grandma to judge them because we
manifested that you have to own a home
and if you did and now you're not just
staying above water and you sold that
home and moved into a shittier
neighborhood or a smaller house or
rented now your actual life can open up
but no the ideology of owning a home and
the inability to take a step backwards
to text three steps forward is gonna
make you unhappy till the end yes
from the extreme of getting somebody in
here this evening to go home and sell
their [ __ ] house to getting to
getting to getting one of you to not buy
a pair of off lights that you can't
afford and those two extremes are no
different than [ __ ] Sallee pants 98
to your mom this is a game of the edges
this is a game of the edges everybody's
focused in the middle 90% 95% 99% of the
[ __ ] you think about and you consumes in
the middle so you don't pay attention to
the edges there's a [ __ ] game of the
edges once you get your relationship
down with the seven [ __ ] people that
matter the most in your life and
actually get to the place of saying I
love you but [ __ ] you and once you get
to that same relationship over here
which is super simple I'm not sure I
even know you and [ __ ] you that's the
game now don't confuse [ __ ] you let me
explain what I mean I roll with empathy
and compassion and sympathy
this isn't [ __ ] you for hate this is I'm
not willing to live my life under your
judgment of what life is because
eventually let me tell you the biggest
mistake people make that I've observed
through the millions of interactions
over the last decade that I consumed
there are people right now that are
living their life still in their 40s and
50s based on the opinion of their
parents they think they're doing the
right thing because they [ __ ]
actually love their parents I get it I
love my parents so uncomfortably much it
scares me but they live it because
they're appeasing lawyer to kids living
in this area doing this job don't take
risks cuz we told you not to we came
from a generation that didn't so you're
doing that or I was once in an
entrepreneur it [ __ ] it up and so we
were scared so now you don't do that
they live for their parents they think
it's good because everything's good cuz
you're doing what your parents want you
feel like it's good
and then life keeps going and then what
starts happening is they start to resent
their parents because now their pop into
their 50th birthday their 60th birthday
their 65th birthday they get a health
scare and they're like [ __ ] I'm not
doing what I want to be doing my friends
until our society and this country
especially redefine success in being
happy not being rich everybody will
continue to go down the path that we're
seeing in our society of depression
anxiety drugs
I believe it the most do I believe that
there's people here that are lucky that
are talented and loves something and
they build a business that you actually
love that process and it makes them a
lot of wealth yes I do
there I'm one of them I genuinely love
my [ __ ] I love it the most thank God
it also manifested in financial success
but if you watched my behavior you would
realize it's the chase when and if the
Jets win the Superbowl before I buy them
I'm probably when and if the Jets win
the Superbowl before I buy them you're
gonna see a video of like 61 year old me
being [ __ ] now I gotta buy the Knicks
what I realized about me about why do I
love garage saleing why have I probably
rolled up some people in this room's
house to buy [ __ ] over the last 10 years
is cuz I love the hunt I wake up at five
o'clock in the morning on a Saturday
after working 90 hours a week because my
hobby is to go to [ __ ] cold wick town
wide sale or [ __ ] mccutchins town
wise sale two times a year to go through
people's trash and buy [ __ ] for a dollar
that's worth seven not because of the
dollar in the seven but because maybe
just maybe this is the day that I roll
up on somebody's house and find a rare
1947 Cracker Jack Green Lantern ring
worth 80,000 and even the eighty
thousand doesn't mean [ __ ] I get to eat
more to stand right here than that I
just want the [ __ ] hunt I want the
[ __ ] game I want to be the greatest
entrepreneur of all time that's why I'm
giving back so much to you cuz I don't
think the greatest entrepreneur of all
time is just the guy or gal that makes
the most money I think it's the one that
brings the most value back to the system
and makes a lot of money you know you
could be awesome you got to make the
money you got a win boat that's what I
want for you
do you have [ __ ] happy I was at 27
making $40,000 a year living in the
villas on Springfield Avenue 20 minutes
from here
[ __ ] work in 15 hours a day seven
[ __ ] days a week building a business
that wasn't even mine
happiest [ __ ] while my friends were
flossing rolling up to my store and
their BMWs that they couldn't afford
clowning behind my back that I was
carrying out their case of champagne I
was [ __ ] plotting
I was in my process I was 27 I was 32
you guys think I'm successful now I'm 43
[ __ ]
I haven't even [ __ ] started I'm being
serious I feel the same way right this
second that I did 20 years ago in that
store I'm plotting I'm processing I'm
enjoying my game and if I overextend
myself and the economy crashes harder
than I thought and it all goes back to
zero I deserve it I love this game so
much even if it comes to a situation
where I have to pay the price of playing
it wrong when we lose an account when
somebody quits that I don't want to when
something investment goes to 0 I get
secretly excited like you know those
weird [ __ ] movies where like there's
that scene where like the person gets
punched in the [ __ ] mouth and you
think they're gonna die and then they
kind of go this way and then they come
back and look at you and like the Bloods
coming down and the [ __ ] and they're
just looking at you and now they're like
oh now I'm [ __ ] bad that's how I live
my life every time something bad happens
I'm more happy than when something good
happens do you know how much I hate
where I'm at right now where now I'm
overrated not underrated anything if I
announce tomorrow that I starting a
candle company 90% of people he knows
something I'm gonna buy some [ __ ]
candles too
I'm [ __ ] overrated now and I [ __ ]
hate it I might move to China and get
the [ __ ] out
I like being underrated I'm underrated I
was an immigrant I didn't speak English
I [ __ ] lost my whole life that's why
I'm winning now my friends this my
friends this is the [ __ ] game you
want to [ __ ] win in life fall in love
with losing because most people are here
are scared of it
I love booing you know my favorite
tennis player is Novak Djokovic you know
why and I know he's a great planner you
know why if you happen to watch
Wimbledon this year you know exactly why
that whole [ __ ] stadium was rooting
for Roger Federer the whole place and
when that [ __ ] beat him he ate
that grass and what he was really saying
was [ __ ] you I'm on some underdog [ __ ]
while people are running around wearing
LeBron and Steph Curry jerseys let me
say it one more time for the kids in the
back I'm on some underdog [ __ ] while
everybody else is wearing jerseys of
winners to make them feel like a winner
the number-one unlock to happiness in
this room is to go out there after this
talk and get naked about your
vulnerabilities what you suck at take a
step back go humble this is about losing
and humility at the forefront and
nobody's talking about it every single
other person talking is talking about
fake it till you make it winning at all
costs look the part before you are it is
that [ __ ] my man
people out here [ __ ] [ __ ] there's
people out here acting like they're
entrepreneurs and their mommy and daddy
are paying for the company you ain't
winnin you're [ __ ] losing in a way
that you can't imagine let me tell you
about the world on living I'm watching
people out here trying to trick losers
I'm trying to win with winners let me
explain when your mom and dad are
subsidizing your business but you're not
telling anybody because you want to look
like you're winning you're losing
because you're building insecurity
you're not winning the only person
you're tricking is other [ __ ] losers
my friends this is real talk I'm coming
here Jersey cuz I'm [ __ ] from here and
I want people to be happy please please
that I mean this especially up there
what's up please please
please please please do not confuse the
last 15 minute rant with audacity or
bravado
or ego please just know that's my
communication style and reread the words
when you get back home this is about
love I'm trying to get people to win I'm
watching real deep sadness and it's not
because of social media social media is
not making you sad your insecurities
making you sad I love you back and
that's it and that's it and even winners
overextend themselves raising too much
capital to take it to the next step and
then they get caught because even with
the winning they still haven't closed
the insecurities it's about insecurity
how would did it get there
how did it get there and I'm just trying
to really put pressure on this
conversation I really am it me as a
store
you have to be either mute or
exclusively listen to me [ __ ] mixing
up Russian English now listen to me
Lucia [ __ ] listen my friends I'm serious
this is super important to me like you
know it's funny when I'm in a zone like
this and I it felt good all day and dude
this was gonna go well when I'm in a
zone like this it's like it's hard for
me to get excited to give you the
tactics you know it's hard for me to
tell you like how to use Instagram
stories or why LinkedIn organics on fire
or how you have to get over yourself and
start a tik-tok account it's the only
place that you get to a half a million
followers for free quick for no reason
on some luck [ __ ] by one viral video
it's hard for me to get going on that
[ __ ] it's hard for me to get you to
understand that if you literally text
every person your phone right now and
ask for help and have the humility and
show that vulnerability good [ __ ] can
happen it's hard for me to give you
those things cuz you won't do them if
you don't address the [ __ ] I started
this talk with and the reason I'm
talking about my man is because I've
been doing this for a minute the reason
I'm showing you guys videos of 2009 bad
haircut fad me is because that dude was
saying the same [ __ ] I'm saying right
now there was less eyes on me but it's
been the same [ __ ] and it's always gonna
be the same [ __ ] there's no hack
there's no passive income let me say it
one more time
there's no passive income there's no
system there's no system that's gonna
allow you if you're making money you got
to watch your money
what do you lay on a beach and
something's gonna be an algorithm and
system we're gonna take care of it even
[ __ ] when people do real estate well
you think that's passive tell people
that owned real estate how passive it is
when there's a [ __ ] leak in the
bathroom or when the maintenance man
quits we're where a tornado takes it out
the [ __ ] are you guys talking about
[Applause]
there's no [ __ ] white tape thing here
with a marker that I can show you some
system zero
there's no system you want to build
something it's hard working talent hard
work and talent and by the way
everybody's got talent some kind some
talent manifests and bigger dollars and
others no doubt but honestly here's the
unlock once you stop chase you many
people are chasing cryptocurrency
cannabis blockchain cuz they think
there's money there and have no idea
what the [ __ ] they're talking about
I do cuz I talk to these [ __ ] every
day you asked them one beat yo I'm a
blockchain expert you asked him one
question they're [ __ ] lost
you know I'm Gary bean I'm starting that
I'm starting to CBD brand I'm like good
bro knock yourself out
people just talking [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] please take my energy here today
cuz it's on rare form to get happy just
get happy yo like [ __ ]
the biggest confusion in America in 2019
is that money is happiness biggest and
everybody I know what's gonna happen
it's gonna post on YouTube and I'm gonna
read the comments I'll be like yo easy
for him to say I'm rich but I'll cry and
my Ferrari until you're crying in your
Ferrari
you know many [ __ ] I know that cry in
their Ferrari a lot cuz I know a lot of
rich people and their satisfy and when
you have money and you're satisfied that
[ __ ] happens cuz that [ __ ] goes from
cognac and weed took cocaine and guns in
your [ __ ] mouth my friends it is time
once and for all
to [ __ ] cut the [ __ ] we need to
start talk about happiness
if you're making 37k a year in this room
as a teacher but you came here to figure
out what business can get you to a
million a year but you [ __ ] skip home
whistling out of happiness because
you're impacting young people's lives
then leave this [ __ ] conference right
now because you [ __ ] won you don't
need anybody I love you so much that I'm
trying to figure out how to say
something in some new way to get one of
you because you've heard this so goddamn
much for me
we don't listen because we don't address
the well we're all making fancy sinks
and wallpaper and decorating our homes
but it's our foundation it's our
foundation it's our foundation and
that's why and that's why I come here
guns blazing by the way I think I should
only talk in New Jersey right [ __ ]
[Applause]
I'm not sure I want to talk anywhere
else the [ __ ] New Jersey
I [ __ ] love you guys I said real [ __ ]
I [ __ ] love you guys and some real
[ __ ]
on some real [ __ ]
[Applause]
my friends it's so easy out here it's so
[ __ ] easy and nobody wants to go
there because you're scared of judgement
just listen the amount of poison that is
sitting in this room is unheard of
there's so much hurt in here and you're
scared to put it out you want to really
get happy go home after this make an
Instagram video and talk about your
uncle abusing you
you stealing money one day you selling
drugs and somebody dying that you knew
because of your drugs that you sold them
the fact that you stole the fact that
you did bad [ __ ] get the poison out of
your mouth
our our poison if you murdered somebody
don't do it you're going to jail but but
for the most part we're just finally
just making a video being like yo I'm
scared
vulnerability is strength like you many
people in here know they're not an
entrepreneur but it says it in their bio
you know why - somehow the [ __ ] that I
got made fun of in the 80s and 90s in
this great state became the cool thing
my friends who's over 42 in this room
raise your hands tell these youngsters
tell these youngsters how not cool
entrepreneurship was it was if you
didn't get good grades and went to a
great school that was it unless you're
an athlete or something but it was like
there was no selling stuff but then
[ __ ] they made a movie and Justin
Timberlake said you know what's cooler
than a million a billion and everybody
went off that's what happened and now
everything and now the [ __ ] now the
baby wants to hang out with me you
understand this is crazy [ __ ] this is
crazy [ __ ] the entrepreneur became the
cool thing which immediately means every
thirteen-year-old on earth right now
wants to be one because quickly at 13
you realize you have no flow and you
don't run fast so you can't you know
what's great about rap and [ __ ]
sports is it's obvious if I was one of
those and somebody's like people roll up
on me all the time Gary I'm an
entrepreneur I can't be like show me but
if somebody's like yo Gary I'm a rapper
might go yo Gary I'm a basketball
founder show me the reason this
entrepreneur thing is so scary is you
can hide you can hide and what I know is
that there's a lot of people in this
room who are number three's who are
number Seven's who are number thirteen
and could be happy let me tell you about
entrepreneurship if you don't have the
stomach for that [ __ ] it will eat you up
it will eat you up to be a great great
entrepreneur you actually can't hear
anything cuz the second you hear
something you won't take the risks or
make the jumps or the moves to actually
go do you know many people are gonna go
out of business in the next two or three
years because they don't have the
humility to show people that they're
actually failing currently so they'd
rather completely go out of business on
some hope [ __ ] it's real out here it's
real out here it's time we listen every
time I hit the stage knowing it's being
recorded I'm like is
this gonna listen I've never had really
outside my first one really I've never
really had a talk goes super duper duper
duper viral I've never had a talk at a
hundred million views you know and every
time I go out here I'm like is this
gonna be the one you know and not
because I give a [ __ ] about a hundred
million of you [ __ ] a hundred million
views because I want this conversation
to go as a matter of fact if all of you
promised me to take this conversation
and make your own version of
conversation so that the collective gets
to 100 million and I get a few a single
view I'm good I'm gonna get everything
by myself like I always have what I want
is what I know is happening in this room
right now which is this is real this is
the actual conversation and every
[ __ ] person in here knows it not
everybody loves it
because you know like if you got to
start thinking about your actual
vulnerabilities you know how much we
hate being honest with ourselves we love
tricking ourselves it feels better it's
not fun to say you suck especially when
you put something on a pedestal
we've put entrepreneurship on a pedestal
and now everybody wants to be good at it
I get it it's just hard like real hard
like really hard guys tonight
let me remind you something how many
people here have a business if you're
not annihilated it right now you suck
this is the easiest time in the history
of America to be successful a business
for everybody that just raised their
hand
that isn't annihilating it you suck
that's not fun for me to say I just
really want to make sure it's done
there's a lot of youngsters and you're a
lot of first-timers even if you're 50
this is the easiest the economy's been
cruising for a decade there's so much
money in this
of course there's things it's easier for
white males to get fun I understand all
that
I've never done funding you can start
from zero many people start from zero if
you're not let me say this super crystal
clear if you're not crushing it right
now in your business it is highly likely
that you're not good at it you might
have just started last week so like you
know you haven't had enough time on some
real [ __ ] cuz I know hands are not gonna
want to go up as much right now how many
people here have been doing their
business for three years raise your
hands raise em high own it
telling you if it's not crushing you got
a problem and that's okay there's a I've
friends at silica like in 2006 that I
would let you know this is when I was
coming up and I was like I don't think
you're good shut down their company and
became the seventh employee at tumblr
and made [ __ ] twelve million dollars
this is self-awareness this is
self-awareness you have to be honest
with yourself because if you're
incapable of that you have no prayer of
happiness and being honest with yourself
is hard being your biggest critic do you
know how delusional
do you know how hard like my friends we
are so good at casting judgment on
everybody else we're unstoppable at that
keyboard warriors on Twitter everyone
we're not doing that to ourselves now do
not confuse that with your grinding and
the company hasn't turned yet and now
you're gonna bail too soon everything is
about balance here's my bigger question
if you're in your six of your company
after this little rant and it's not
crushing but you're happy as [ __ ] you
won
[Music]
take a step back with me and listen to
the last 13 minutes and let's talk about
it one more time I come out we talked
about the pressure on you should be
succeeding because it's easy you're not
you're three years in you're not now
you're feeling like ah [ __ ] [ __ ] Gary
Vee you know
but then the twist at the end if you
[ __ ] love it let's go let me tell you
why I'm scared and what I want to push
into the system right now I believe the
following I believe that there's a lot
of people here whose business is
unsuccessful because they're aiming to
make it a ten million dollar business
and they don't have it in them had they
taken a step back and instead of doing a
business around real estate investing or
cannabis or CBD or social or a t-shirt
brand or whatever the [ __ ] if they took
a step back and said okay cuz everybody
comes in hi every kid that starts a
t-shirt brand rolls into my office or my
demons like yo I'm about to build a next
supreme I'm like no you're not anybody
who's gonna build the next supreme
doesn't tell somebody they're building
the next supreme they tell themselves
but if you took a step back and actually
said what do I [ __ ] like like what do
you like like what are you about what
are your interests what do you like how
do you take a step back and focus on
what you like and then build a practical
business around that I so believe in
that [ __ ] now that business might be
84,000 a year if you like Smurfs and you
start a [ __ ] Smurfs podcast and sell
Smurfs hoodies I do not believe that
business is gonna do 8.3 million a year
my question is which ones better
is it better to be happy hit on a number
and live within those means or is it
better to listen to macro trends [ __ ]
that you don't want chase the money and
make yourself vulnerable and unhappy
that's the big and by the way there's a
lot of people who have the great fortune
of loving something that allows them to
make dollars there's a lot of people who
just love the process of business I'm
one of them I can love anything nothing
whether its garage sale or selling
services or wine if my dad had a tire
store I would have built the biggest
[ __ ] tire store
world some people just like that and
that's fine too but honestly this is one
enormous game of self-awareness enormous
around really getting into your skills
the skills can be taught my friends
Google and YouTube will teach you
everything what do you want to know
Google and YouTube will teach it to you
do you want the tactics Google and
YouTube will teach it to you you want to
build a website with a funnel that
creates a subscription business free
Google YouTube Google YouTube this is
not about Google YouTube this is not
about the tactics this is about the
structure the strategy the
self-awareness the mindset and really
taking this conversation deeper to
really know what you're about and how
you got here to change up your [ __ ] you
have to do new [ __ ] there's so many
people here on your 20 of trying to
figure it out to get there but they've
been doing the same thing in different
ways just listening to a different voice
a different ebook a different seminar
but doing the same hustle with a
different disguise you want new [ __ ] you
got to do new [ __ ] you got to try
something different I'm proposing an
alternative to the masses of what I see
out there patience you know why I push
it you can't build anything meaningful
in a [ __ ] year every so why people
buy lottery tickets
it's not gonna work you're welcome
I'm done let's do Q an egg thank you
[Music]
I think we're doing QA right there and I
think there's it's your the line is
there another line I don't know okay
let's start over here are we doing
double mics think all right let's get
right into it
now we get into the good part go ahead
my man hey Gary
so my partner and I steal their business
my partner's killed our business My
partner and I from zero 350 in the first
ten months
350 okay sorry I was getting excited and
then in the first six months ten months
ten months all right now what doing
apparel apparel
so it's I can't really say the most
legitimate thing and we need to have
someone to acquire it now we've had
someone offer it
the thing is though they want us to be a
consultant like a marketing consultant
social media consulted just a consultant
for the whole business for everything
and we're trying to figure out how the
[ __ ] we like leverage our assets like
our Facebook pixel and just our
knowledge because we're both really
green into the end of the market still I
why do you want to sell it because we
need like a lot of Licensing and I say
you don't you're talking about how you
have it like it gets too big it actually
goes to zero
exactly so then sell it yeah and so I
overthink the very much we're gonna be
in their team as well so we're gonna
hide [ __ ] on the business and then we're
gonna help in other businesses besides
the whole logistics with the business
we're gonna sell it for the mentorship
and just to learn I understand you're
young yeah exactly
okay so uh but then how relied for
leverage like being a consultant because
there's really no mathematical number
there to like determine I'm not
leveraging the consultancy you're not
leveraging that's a bad word how do you
maximize it yes ask for more money okay
like literally no joke and now I
understand what you're saying so you're
trying to figure out you know there's a
multiple against the 350 and then you're
trying to figure out well how much
should we get for the consulting yes
over to the two-year period a three year
period or whatever the contract state
exactly this is for everybody always ask
for the craziest number that you think
is possible okay now I don't think you
should ask for 10 million a year if that
doesn't make logical sense whatever
number you have in your mind per year
double it okay that all right good thank
you you're welcome
mic yep fine good what was your first
business my first business was 20
minutes from here on tingly lane in New
Jersey at us in New Jersey I was I was
just turned six and I would go to
people's yards and I would rip their
flowers out of their yard and I would
ring their doorbell and I would sell it
back to that now Michael
couple thinks because I have to shoot it
straight up here I'm not necessarily
proud of that and when you look cute
like you do now and I did then you could
get away with that [ __ ] but that [ __ ]
goes away quick that's like a crime so
make sure you don't [ __ ] up okay bro
sup buddy good to see you so before I
say anything you see that number on a
study that changed my life I'm so highly
suggest that all of you text that number
right [ __ ] now because I'm interning
for Gary next summer and because
literally my last week of my internship
last summer I texted him hey can I
intern for you he said sure email d-roc
access access that number right there is
access so I just want to start off with
that and I actually did have a question
because I know we had like I said many
conversation before so in terms of like
with everything with the Relay for Life
and everything I was passing it off to
my roommate there Brian yep and it's
this is a little higher level stuff that
like you'll definitely understand
passing something off
that's your baby is devastating it's
it's it shook my whole structure can I
give you a very easy answer because I
want to get to a lot of them when you
pass something you've made a decision to
not be in control the end podcast is a
people who made things happen at
official Mandor on his screen thank you
what do you sir what he's referring to
is like when I left Wine Library it was
really hard for me to watch what my dad
did with it that's real but I left once
you give up the wheel you don't get the
passed judgement and people struggle
with that if you want to control it get
back in the [ __ ] seat hi oh okay hi
Gary also immigrant from Belarus awesome
I came here nine years ago just like a
little back story with nothing not
knowing anybody I didn't speak English
like no papers none of that yep so
because of that in the meantime I tried
a hundred things possible yes to hustle
and survive in love with some loved some
of them and hated the least but
inevitably even things that I loved the
most I kind of lost interest so for me
is like cuz you don't love them
I did know you did it you hooked up with
them honestly it's really cool like I'm
glad we're having this combo you think
you loved him but you didn't you like
them for a period of time you never
stopped the thing you loved I promise
you what I'm doing right this second I
will do to my last breath you're smart
enough to know you have not tried
everything possible that you have thank
you hey Gary thanks 42 years old when I
was in tenth grade I wanted to be a
barber more than anything
hmm everyone told me it wasn't gonna be
a thing I went to school my mom signed
me up she then enrolled with me really
embarrassing the newspaper came in and
asked me what do you want to do I said
there were no barber schools in town I
had to go to cosmetology and cut women's
hair which helped me a lot in my core
and they asked me what I wanted to do
and I said one day I want to open up a
school I've been doing everything that
I've said I was gonna do since I was in
tenth grade I wanted to be a singer
first but I fell in love with hair and
creativity I'm the only owner of the
most successful barber school in
Philadelphia I love it
I don't say that in arrogance I get it I
started with three hundred dollars from
my first barbershop again I know the
grind I know the mud I know the dirt yep
I do a live feed every Tuesday 9:30 a.m.
I only have 58 thousand followers I get
200 something that's about 15,000 more
than most absolutely I understand I'm
saying I get 200 views of watching my
live content every Tuesday love I
haven't been able to grow and I should
grandma get past that but not just
Instagram my business for my school yep
ninety ten less than ninety percent of
my income comes from government funding
ten percent or more has to come from
cash business or whatever self pay
military aid whatever I want to flip it
and get from 10 to 90 and not have to
rely on the government so that the
government yes says that my voters can't
come your phone who I want to get out of
owner ability so don't so let's go I
mean that's that's what I'd like to do
so my question is how do I get to that
point because I've been putting in the
work we put out content every single day
do you run at absolutely how much
absolutely every day we're putting stuff
out every single day how much what do
you say how much what is what do you
mean Oh money we do find a thousand
dollars in five thousand dollars on
Facebook ads a month okay but we're
doing Instagram push notice three
absolutely yeah absolutely swipe up all
that how's it doing it's doing well I'm
getting a lot of engagement I'm getting
a lot of engagement and we're getting
enrollments without paying for ads like
look what I'm talking about ads until
you're talking about scaling and that's
where we're playing with you on this you
need to make if you're spending five
thousand dollars a month you need to
make the CAC and the LTV work CAC
customer acquisition costs deter LTV
lifetime value you want to get off the
way you do is actually build a humongous
business the way you do that is you find
a channel in the world Direct Mail
commercials print ads then Google
AdWords then email then social and write
you find a place where if you're putting
five thousand into the system my
question is how
general enrollment so we did about eight
to ten students um enrollment per month
we already have 12 on the list and a
waiting list right now okay without
doing Google ads and an amazing website
just from social okay just from social
that's it
so that's $17,000 per student to go to
our program and how much profit do you
make against that so we're at were we're
not in the red anymore I mean currently
my business is worth 2.5 somewhere close
to that the last time I checked you mean
by multiple top-line revenue I mean
where it were not into red where green
we're doing well but I'm afraid that if
we lose government aid that could affect
our business tremendously no it will and
we're changing people's lives that's the
thing I'm creating so much value you
have to run ads against your profit to
convert better return on the ad spend
okay I also think you need to go heavy
organic tik-tok okay hey I mean it I got
you hey you know everyone's gonna regret
this is the [ __ ] same show I've been
living my whole life let's do this about
YouTube and Instagram whatever tick tock
got it all right okay one more thing yes
I want to come on the show and if you
say no it's okay no I get it no gee I'm
gonna do the tsx
okay I'm gonna do the gsx it's expensive
I got you I'm looking at it however
don't do it I don't like where you're
recognized okay you don't do it here's
what I'm saying I want to know how and
when it knows the answer today keep
asking different ways got it thank you
hey Gary Vee my name is Bobby Jones and
my question i'ma try to make it quick
but it's got a little bit of a backstory
so grew up foster care got into a ton of
trouble as soon as I was old enough to I
actually went to jail and numerous times
my daughter was born while I was in
there and I got to a point where I was
almost gonna do life in prison I got
miraculously saved came home busted my
ass got a nine-to-five soon as the
nine-to-five sealing like kind of
presented itself I started my own
business my business has grown 49% over
the last three years and I've gotten to
a point where it pretty much runs itself
and I've gotten a lot of my time back
I'm really happy with where it is and
I've been able to do a lot with youth
justice asked for at-risk youth going
back and speaking to detention centers
and different schools and alternative
programs
and I really really love doing that and
I get a ton of feedback and I've been
asked to do more good but I'm my
question is at what point cuz I could
probably keep with my business and grow
it to ten million and really have a
better platform to explore that more but
I don't love it the way that I love
doing these discussions and speaking and
helping
push hard from both sides where's it at
right now it's at three million great
how I hear it if I was like your brother
I'd be like yo bro okay so three to ten
is full pot committed and here's the
talking let's take it from three to six
and do both the answer to so many
questions is both yeah you just got a
cut out dumb [ __ ] I'm also doing some
real estate investing in another
business as well so it's gonna get to
that point all right thank you very you
got better hey Gary how are you I'm
great how are you um well my dad's name
was Gary passed last year so sorry to
hear that love you thank you thank my
name is drew berman from drewberman.com
and my book just came out proud of it
it's called dads thanks so much thank
you so it's called it's called you can
have it all and I studied marketing in
college and I ended up picking the
profession network marketing so I've
been in network marketing for 17 years
and I've never dabbled with it I never
took it part-time and I ended up making
a career out of it okay but your talk
was pretty powerful because there's a
lot of people who where a network
marketing hat and don't even have a clue
about networking or marketing or network
marketing or what it means to own a
business and it tends to be a fall in
your lap type of business people fall
into it because they find a product that
they like or they find a friend that
introduces them and a lot of people a
lot
Gary hundreds of thousands are clueless
okay so the question the book teaches
people how to do it right understood and
that's a commercial what's the question
the quote the commitment the question is
it's an industry that's completely on
its vertical upswing okay and I feel
this can help a lot of people so I'm
building platforms on all the platforms
and again you know whatever you're
mentioning tick tock if you were doing
that if you were gonna launch to that
particular in just yet
how would you brand yourself how would
you brand a brand new book I think it's
all about communicating contextual to
the platform so the way I think about
branding is communicating telling your
truth
but then respecting the algorithms and
the features and the mindset of that
people consuming it on the other side
everybody here is actually a different
person when they're in their Instagram
feed versus when they're in their
Pinterest board versus when they're on
LinkedIn this is a mindset context
content game not just a content and
blast to all platforms that's what I
would do get a gift you more happy to do
it let's go hi first I want to say thank
you you're the [ __ ] i binge watch you
before i go to sleep so i am all up in
your face before you my name is Meg I
started my business curly hair alchemist
loved it
I just went digital so I have a salon
open I've had a brick-and-mortar for a
year but I've been open under myself for
three years okay I do about 1,600
services a year so that means I touched
1,600 people's heads yes I'm the top
stylist I plan on hiring people next
year I don't know how to do that figure
it out can I give you a quick one on
that please don't overthink it yeah tell
them the truth
yes and when they don't deliver on the
truth fire them okay people struggle
with scaling [ __ ] like you're doing just
people overthink it yeah I may have ego
that I'm the only one that does it best
and then nobody's ever good enough go
with in humility tell them the truth and
then if they don't deliver on it fire
I've watched so many people that are
great at their craft never build a
business because of ego that they like
feeling that they're better at this
thing than anybody then actually scaling
a business okay got you go ahead I just
went digital okay I'm launching my
online course in November first quads
curls hold magic blueprint okay I pre
sold for seventy seven dollars and 33
cents I
have 49 members in my program okay I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
that's best so so what's happening is
what I'm I have a plan on how to how to
engage I feel like what I do behind the
chair is very valuable I touch people's
hearts I send them home they feel
beautiful love it right how can I do
that digitally and piggybacking off that
but I don't by talking to them yes I
write but I mean no no no I understand
no I'm very vulnerable on camera no no
at them well then right right don't go
on camera just write it yeah oh man I'm
bad all right okay stick with me okay
then record the memo and send it to them
okay
you're a communicator oh so my mouth
yeah well if you if you get if some
people freeze when the camera is the
addition however you have gift of gab in
just audio so just do a memo and blast
it to them
gotcha it's about communication all
right because I'm not behind the chair I
feel insecure about being discord record
blammo when I when you're behind a chair
yeah that's just keep constant rate all
right I'll get back to you okay
hi hi hi I just wanted to say thank you
for your honesty and transparency but
I'm from Charlottesville Virginia okay
and I became a brand ambassador for a
nonprofit called soles for Souls they
focused on wearing out poverty virus
redistributing shoes okay so three
months ago I launched a shoe drive on
collecting twenty five thousand pairs
okay I'm at about twenty five hundred
and I just wanted to see if you'd be
willing to ask caseless if they could
donate thank you you got it can you just
email me right now and say I'm the lady
that from Virginia that asked for the
case with stuff thank you I will hook it
up
[Applause]
hey yo Gary and by the way if they don't
I will
Gary just want to say thank you
personally just to tell you very quickly
a lot of people would consider what I do
daily for a career successful on paper
and you've fully convinced me to do what
I'm passionate about and do what I love
and I'm officially making this my last
year doing that to move towards what I
want so thank you for that and listen
listen this is such an important part of
this conversation cuz I'm scared
shitless of people quit and [ __ ] off
quick I'm going on some fantasy journey
and that I'm the [ __ ] that [ __ ] them
up so let me go real quick with this
here's why I'm passionate about it
you're so young that you're not gonna
have to live with regret that you didn't
try because when and if you fail at
whatever you're about to do you can
always go back to this you can always go
back to the thing you don't love
[Music]
so my question is my team and I have
been forming a finance consultancy for
solar dealers and we're currently based
out of Pennsylvania okay what we intend
to do is try to glow this to a national
scale eventually and right now my
question is is do I start engaging with
clients in a smaller market like
Pennsylvania or move to a bigger market
like California do you want to move to
California I would move anywhere to make
this afternoon do you think it's too
competitive in California based on what
the market is for what we're providing
to as our services now then you should
go to California done thank you hi Gary
how are you I'm good I want to say I
been DMing you since February 2017 geez
and I and I sucked but I've been
grinding Wow respect so and your shoes
are flies fun thank you thank you thank
you so I am a 52 year old mother of four
and I I have a luxury clothing brand
called hearts for and that's har x4 okay
and I recently just did last season of
Project Runway Wow and thank you and now
I'm at a point where I'm rebranding cuz
I lost a whole lot of money why I don't
have any money producer I was doing
things
dumb [ __ ] I was exams putting the cart
before the horse I'm doing New York
Fashion Week and I can't even produce a
product impatience girl
exactly so now while everyone talks
about content yep so I'm trying to
determine do I tell a story or do I
build mediocre content meaning editorial
content why is that why is it media
because I have a luxury brand and I
can't compete with the people that I'm
on the racks with next to insects if I
don't have a product why that's why you
assume that the content has to be high
production value to be considered
quality because what I see in magazines
in the newspapers that people make it
myself you're looking backwards you're
looking backwards you know this do
you think a 52 year old woman would look
as fly as you 20 years ago now correct
stick with me we've all changed right
the gentleman the barber 42 I'm looking
at him like for everybody over 40 right
all of us we know you know exactly what
I'm taking this the youth of vacation
millionaires did not look like this 20
years ago right I'd have a dumbass suit
4250 look at you you look 18 no no I'm
trying to make a point here I'm telling
you right now that high glossy [ __ ]
photo shoot that you can't afford to be
in [ __ ] vogue doesn't work the same
way anymore
just like 50 do you understand what I'm
saying yes yeah so stop making judgment
on the past and start being practical of
what you can do instead of dwelling on
what you can't do okay thank you
and look it look more like the end all
right sport I'll look for it all right
last one I'm sorry I'm so so I know I'm
the word I'd [ __ ] bro what'd he want
I've got a charity event I gotta go to
you don't like charity
my name is Jennifer Paradis I'm the CEO
of sacred seeds for you dot-com a
natural skincare company though I had
been doing it on the side for 20 years I
was I I left from my job I lost three
friends back to back to back and that's
guys Edwards side four days later Tom
patch action real say two weeks later
another friend so I went to my job and I
quit I didn't have the nest egg I didn't
have it prepared you know I it was
though everybody leaving I love you see
it was the whole leap and the net will
appear yep but that puts me in a
position where I'm burning the candle at
a lot of more on the solopreneur course
that a Reiki person talked to me and she
knew about the chest pains I get us
having so I don't want the bird but
dress a lot that I want to do a lot that
I'm trying to reach and with the natural
skin care basket I guess no one ate it
so like homeless are God's victims of
domestic uestion so how can I avoid the
burnout and then how can I have you help
me donate to more people to the homeless
to the people in the inner city to get
Edwards book outside I don't want to
[ __ ] you and make promises I can't
deliver so I don't know you'll have to
send me an email to Gary vaynermedia I
got to understand what the [ __ ] you're
actually asking for and talking about as
far as burning from both sides you can
readjust people burn out because they
need something to happen faster put
yourself in a position to let it happen
slower you've got to think about your
expenses you got to think you there's
only two things either you can't afford
to keep doing it or you want it to get
big too fast I've got it look at both
the one that you can't afford you got to
change your expenses whatever that may
be home travel the cost of goods or if
you want a cue fast you have to flip
your framework and realize that you're
still young and can get to it you got
[ __ ] 40 years to actually do it
not four months even though we've lived
a little you understand yeah it's just
the fragility is life and you keep
burying people like that you know but
you can't boil the ocean everybody out
here is trying to change everybody here
is trying to change the world change
yourself first
I Love New Jersey
I see you up there thank you so much
thank you so much
[Applause]